In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 3rd, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hyromarter, Dionysius, the Ariopagite.
On the 3rd of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hyromarter, Dionysius, the
Ariopagite.
And Dionysius, who came of a rich and noble family, lived in Athens at the time of the apostles.
On account of the wisdom and virtue pagan learning afforded him, he was chosen one of the
nine counselors of the Ariopagus, the High Court and Parliament of the city.
As such it was he who invited the great apostle Paul, whom the Holy Spirit had brought to
the city to proclaim the good tidings of salvation on the Ariopagus.
From the height of this rock, overlooking the city, the simple tentmaker pulled to pieces
the sophistries of the Athenian philosophers and clearly showed that the unknown God,
whom their unassisted reason had given them a vague notion of, was the Lord of heaven
and earth, who made the world and everything in it, and who does not live in temples made
by hands, as though he needed anything, since he himself gives to all men life and breath
and everything.
He told them that man is made in the image of God and is called upon to share the divine
life in the very Son of God, Jesus Christ, who has taken our flesh, has risen from the
dead and will come to judge the world.
Most of the audience mocked St. Paul, unhearing about the resurrection of the dead, since
the false wisdom of this world had completely darkened their minds.
And so the hearts of several among them, including St. Dionysius and St. Yetothil's, were
touched by these words of eternal life, and they believed.
When St. Paul spoke of the Savior's passion and of the portance that occurred at his death,
Dionysius recalled the solar eclipse, inexplicable to astronomers that had happened years before
when he was in Egypt, completing his studies among learned men at Heliopolis.
Either God is suffering, he had cried out then, or this is the end of the world.
This event prepared Dionysius and his master Yetothil's to recognize him who overcomes the
laws of nature when he saw wills, so they listened eagerly to the holy apostles' teaching
and asked him for baptism.
After some time St. Paul departed to endure new tribulations and lift St. Yetothil's as
Bishop of Athens.
Like the eagle that can look directly upon the brightness of the sun, Yetothil's was able
to enter into the mysteries of God, but he wrote little, choosing rather to instruct his
disciple Dionysius, orally, concerning the revelations beyond all speech that God granted
him.
On Yetothil's death Dionysius became Bishop of Athens in his stead.
God enabled him by his grace to put into writing the sublime teachings of his master about
the unutterable boundlessness of the divine nature, to which none but the negative terms
of apophatic theology are applicable, and about the unfathomable riches of his revelation
through his names and energies, that is the sum of affirmative theology.
He described how the sensible world that perceived by our senses and the intelligible world that
apprehended by the illumined intellect are united to God in a magnificently ordered hierarchy.
He explained how the ecclesiastical hierarchy, from the bishop to the monk, manifests upon
the earth the nine orders of angels, and how the divine light is distributed to each person
according to his degree of purification.
Though some people have accused Saint Dionysius of borrowing the terminology of the neoplatonic
philosophers, the Orthodox Church, enlightened by his divine teachings, believes rather that
it is the latter who have borrowed his language, albeit without being able to show, as does
the saint, that he who is beyond every name and all being, and who dwells in the darkness
more radiant than light, has appeared in the flesh so as to make us partakers of his light.
Saint Dionysius attended such heights of divine contemplation that he was accounted worthy
of being numbered among the apostles, and was wondrously transported to Jerusalem for the
entombment of the mother of God.
On his return to Athens, he devoted himself for some time to converting the pagans and
to guiding his spiritual flock.
Towards the end of Nero's reign, he visited Rome to give his master Saint Paul an account
of his missionary activity.
He was present at Paul's martyrdom and then returned to Greece.
On a later visit to Rome, Saint Dionysius and his disciples, the priest Rousticus and
the Deacon Elifetios, were commissioned by Saint Clement, the bishop of Rome, to preach
the gospel in Gaul.
When he had preached the word of truth in a good many places, Dionysius settled in Paris,
which was then a small town sunk in the darkness of ignorance and paganism.
He built a church there in which he served the Holy Mysteries and proclaimed the great works
of God.
He worked many miracles so that in a while the number of his disciples increased and they
set out to spread the Holy Gospel in Britain as far as Spain.
The renown of Saint Dionysius aroused the envy of the devil, who gave the emperor
demission to understand that the Greek bishop, who was preaching a new God, was trying
to provoke disorder and revolt.
The imperial officers tried in vain to persuade Dionysius and his companions to deny God, for
whom they lived and wished to die, and so on being sentenced to beheading the martyrs
were overjoyed.
Not only did God give the Holy Bishop the grace of knowledge and of teaching, but he also
wanted to show in his martyrdom that by faith Christians have overcome death.
So when Dionysius had been beheaded, he stood up to the amazement of all, took his head
in his hands, and walked thus for two miles until he met Cattula, a godly woman, to whom
he gave this precious relic.
Saint Dionysius' skull is now venerated in the monastery of Dochiadio on Mount Athos, to which
it was given by the emperor Alexius Comnenus in the 11th century.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.